how's this dude still alive he's not a
neuro dude this is a man by Handsome
Carla I'm Lester here we're on the set
of Avengers I've been lucky enough along
with other guardians of the galaxy to
join up with the Avengers and be here
and get an opportunity to save the world
does it make you an Avenger now as well
I don't know maybe like a third string
of n-draft because one of the founding
members yeah thank you he's huge you
know out of all the people that I've had
the good fortune to work with these two
particular guys and the triumvirate that
we formed together
it's very special friendship and
decade-plus
of time together yeah it's been this
witnessing of like people's lives
growing and changing it's been a really
cool experience working with Lizzy has
been really really awesome and I think
there is something very powerful about
being able to play women who do heroic
things and those women are so awesome so
we've had a really good time
hanging out with everyone on the set is
one of the best parts of this job
actually because it does have this kind
of large extended family feel I had a
bit of a bucket is someone where the
practice I thought he'd be good fun I'm
proven completely wrong in that front he
was odd Lluis and boring and not
particularly funny
well at first Blanche it's hard to know
what to make a Cumberbatch and then the
more time I spent with him on and off
set I've just kind of been fated with
this guy I was thinking you know the
journey that Robert Downey jr. is made
he's the Godfather of all this it's
literally been the adventure of a
lifetime
I get a little misty thinking about it
so you know I lucked out
[Music]
the adventure of a lifetime let's hope
that that lifetime continues a little
bit longer so hey everybody is Charlie
we got a whole bunch of New Avengers
footage to break down they cut this
behind-the-scenes funny moments along
with footage from the actual movie so
I'll just go through this piece by piece
but it's a really Iron Man story across
all these other storylines you get some
sound bites from the other characters
like you have both of the Chris's on
screen because Thor is a big part of the
guardians storyline early in the film
but really it's them jumping back and
forth - Robert Downey jr. it's been the
adventure of a lifetime in Mark Ruffalo
just hugging him for almost every bit of
screen time that he has during this
trailer talking about how he's the crazy
Godfather of it all and what this
amazing tenure journey has been for him
they really are using this to hype up
Iron Man and while that might make you
feel uneasy like hate does this mean
that they're gonna kill him off because
they're giving him so much attention
before the movie comes out like they
really want you to care about him most
of what we've seen from Avengers 4
implies that he's a big part of that
movie meaning that I don't think that he
dies during infinity war I think they
want you to think that anybody can die
like they have all these weird Captain
America moments where it looks like
Thanos is gonna pop him like a grape or
Iron Man getting a complete beatdown you
don't see him anywhere in any of the
Wakanda scenes that we've seen in the
trailers so you're just wondering what's
going on with him later in the film they
just want to leave it all up in the air
in the 20 minutes that they've been
screening for people the past couple of
weeks that you've probably been hearing
about doesn't give you any information
about what happens to them during the
film before I forget there is a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
I'll mention it again at the end of the
video so no worries but obviously they
just opened this with the scene of the
Guardians grabbing Thor out of space and
him waking up this isn't breaking after
Drax is funny line he's not a dude
you're a dude if you look at this set
behind the two of them here this just
looks like it's more of that ship it
just really opens so that it can fit big
cameras in there so like these windows
look like the windows that Thor is
looking at up but we've seen in the
trailer so far there is some new footage
that we haven't seen before and I'll
talk about it when we get to it but
there's just like a whole bunch of stuff
in here
this footage of Pepper Potts watching
Iron Man take off from their house could
be from an old movie it's kind of hard
to tell Gweneth Paltrow hasn't aged a
whole lot like they put makeup on her
and she looks almost exactly like she
did during the Iron Man movies which
were actually a law
time ago it doesn't seem like it was
that long ago but you do get a shot of
her with Robert Downey jr. and happy on
screen in her special base layer for her
armor so it does sound like she's gonna
have her own rescue armor from the
comics whatever it looks like it'll
probably look something like the comics
but like the bleeding edge armor that
Ironman wears is only inspired by his
comic book bleeding edge armor like the
model prime armor is a little bit
different so just expect the same
treatment for Pepper Potts but I
wouldn't be surprised if he has the
nanites that he also gave that to her
too but we might not see her armor up
til Avengers 4 so like this scene could
have been from the set of Avengers 4 but
like 99% of this footage does definitely
appear from infinity war so this also
could be from whatever intro scene that
she has before Ironman heads to the
sanctum to talk to dr. strange there is
a lot of Iron Man and Doctor Strange I
loved the fact that they addressed the
idea of them hanging out like the more I
got to know Benedict Cumberbatch the
more I fell in love with them so you
have Sherlock bros on set but you also
have Robert Downey jr. wearing his cloak
of levitation in the movie these are
special movie texts that are arranging
it on him like they're getting ready to
film a scene and he's really excited
about it so it sounds like whatever
they're doing Doctor Strange loans it to
him for a second or maybe they have a
funny scene where he tries it on like
dr. strange isn't wearing it you just
wonder what he's thinking in this moment
does this make me the new sorcerer
supreme I think it does if you are a
marvel true believer you may remember
the what-if story where what if Ironman
became the sorcerer supreme and it was
like a combination of a cool concept
with a joke on the fact that their
relative backstories are extremely
similar like that was one of the big
jokes when Doctor Strange came out
they're like isn't this kind of the same
origin story as Ironman doesn't it kind
of play out with the same beats
what if Ironman the technologist the
industrialist went in studied magic
became the next sorcerer supreme so what
ended up happening though is that he
still ended up building his Ironman
armor but because he was sorcerer
supreme
he actually combined his use of
technology with spell casting so that
his armors AI like Jarvis actually knew
how to cast spells he had them
programmed into his Iron Man armor you
get a lot more of this Scotland foot
we're Scarlet Witch envision our just
hanging out on vacation and the black
order come for the mine jump she takes
off out of the window remember she can
fly she doesn't do it that often but you
do get a couple other angles of them
together you get more footage of her on
the wakandan battlefield there was a
shot in the trailer that I posted
yesterday to where she just completely
loses her like she's had ten cups
of coffee and she's shooting laser beams
out of her eyes like that's how crazy
she's going he get more of the
behind-the-scenes from them on the
planet Titan with this big green screen
behind them and it looks like Chris
Pratt is breaking into another dance
bros routine remember that Tom Holland
did Billy Elliot look Benedict
Cumberbatch making fun of Chris Pratt
too and then you get that brand-new
scene of star-lord just going boom in
falling backwards through one of dr.
Strange's portals been a lot of dr.
strange portal related comedy in the
last couple of films Robert Downey jr.
is wearing a slightly different mocap
outfit for this big Titan battle but
that's probably just because they're on
this green screen here they just changed
that depending on what kind of set that
they're shooting on but you do get a
little bit of him practically in the
suit and you can kind of see like this
little black glass area where the arc
reactor normally goes that's probably
just because they have a light inside
there that they physically turn on when
they're filming scenes but most of this
is just to provide reference for all the
post-production people because like 90%
of the scenes with Ironman in the
Ironman armor in movies is done in
post-production most of the time it's
Robert Downey jr. walking around in a
t-shirt with dots all over him like this
really cool shot of Stan Lee I don't
know if this is because they were
getting ready to film his cameo this day
or if he was just visiting the set we
don't know what his cameos are gonna be
in the next two films well let me know
in the comments what your favorite part
of that and if they're any questions you
have about this that I didn't address
during the video just let me know in the
comments the really cool thing that's
happened the last couple days is because
they've been doing more and more press
interviews the directors have clarified
what's going on with the Hawkeye
storyline
they've even teased that they're pushing
for a Secret Wars movie with x-men
crossover once the Foxx deal goes to
so there's all kinds of Avengers stuff
to talk about leave all your video
requests in the comments but there is a
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that just be a subscriber or leave a
comment on the video I'll name a winner
when I post new Marvel which will
probably be tomorrow click here for that
danos trailer where he has four of the
gems in the gauntlet and click here for
brand new flash and Titans thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you